Speaker 1: . In addition, by the way,
as we get into this next story to not
allowing them to rewrite the history of the
pandemic, and we're actually going to speak to
Nicholas Christakis about this very, very
important topic. We also need to do something
to say, guys, the trivialization of the Holocaust
and the comparisons between saying you should
get a vaccine or get to get a test every week
or if you're Fox News, get a test every day.
Comparing that to Nazis killing Jews, it's time
for it to stop. And we're going to have a clip
today that is going to perfectly illuminate
for you. Why Dr. Anthony Fauci needs security.
Why does a doctor need a security team? Partially,
it's because of what I'm about to play for you.
This is a clip of Lara Logan, who has gone
completely off the deep and dangerously so,
likening Dr. Anthony Fauci to the Nazi doctor
Joseph Mengele of Auschwitz concentration camp
fame. OK. Let's just listen to the
clip. I mean, there's no I don't
think we need any further introduction.
Speaker 3: It's that compare very much to
seasonal flu. And so in that moment, what you
see on Dr. Fauci, this is what people say to me
that he doesn't represent science to them. He
represents Josef Mengele, Dr. Joseph Memed, the
doctor, the Nazi doctor who did experiments
on Jews during the Second World War and in
the concentration camps. And I am talking about
people all across the world are saying this big.
Speaker 1: Yeah, everybody's saying it. Dr.
Fauci, people, if you go to New Zealand,
New Zealanders are going, you know, over in the
U.S. that Dr. Fauci, he's like, Josef Mengele.
What the hell is she talking about? This is why
one of the nation's top doctors, an infectious
disease doctor during a pandemic. You've got a
pandemic. You've got an infectious disease doctor.
He needs security. Why does he need security?
Because of stuff like this? Now, for those of
you who don't know much about Joseph Mengele, he
was known as the Angel of Death. He would perform
experiments, many of which resulted in death on
prisoners at the Auschwitz concentration camp
during the Holocaust. Mengele was a member of the
group of doctors who would choose who gets killed
in the gas chambers. He was one of the doctors
who administered the gas. And Lara Logan says all
over the world, people are saying people that Dr.
Fauci is like Josef Mengele. Now, I think. It it's
I should mention. And this is kind of, you know,
it might this might sound like a non sequitur.
A lot of people wrote to me after I played this
clip on yesterday's live stream and said, David,
you know, you got to be careful with Lara Logan
because she she was beaten and sexually assaulted
when she was covering the Egyptian revolution in
2011. Now, that's absolutely horrifying. It is.
It is a tragedy, and it is unimaginable what
happened to Lara Logan and if her now being
off the deep end relates to that trauma,
that's also absolutely terrible. Still.
Saying that Foushee is like Josef Mengele only
worsens the disastrous situation that we find
ourselves in today. Lara Logan has been a purveyor
of disinformation recently. She has continually
fallen for antifa hoaxes. Back in May, she
tweeted out a picture of a document that she said
was the Antifa battle plan, which includes that
Antifa has infiltrated law enforcement and all.
It was a total hoax. She signal boosted it. Lara
Logan then posted a picture of a tweet supposedly
coming from an antifa group, saying We're going to
go and terrorize white neighborhoods. It was fake.
It was from a white nationalist group. She just
constantly falling for this stuff. I could go on.
This is not good. And so whatever. Lara Logan is
going through personally. It's a tragedy. I feel
terribly about it. It's it's unimaginable horror
that she suffered in 2011 covering the Egyptian
revolution and what she's doing publicly
in 2021. Almost 2022 in the media sphere
is completely deplorable, and she must be
stopped at some point. Someone has to say
this isn't responsible and she must be stopped.
Let me know your thoughts. I do want to remind
everybody on December 14th, it's almost December.
On December 14th, we will be doing our final
David Pakman Show Viewer Townhall of the Year.
This is where we open the phone lines and
we just take call after call after call. People
can call in. It is going to be streaming online
only on the Pacman Live YouTube channel.
This is our second channel. You find it at
youtube.com slash Pacman life. It's free to watch
and it's free to call in. OK December 14th 6:00
p.m. Eastern. If you want the priority access to
speaking to me on that day, get a membership on
our website. Members do get priority on the town
halls. You can sign up at join Pacman dot com